if you're watching this you probably
have seen at least one video by business
casual
the channel is a great example of what's
possible in terms of business
entertainment content on youtube
and is definitely an influence on some
of my videos but the channel went silent
about a year ago
and i wanted to find out why so i dug
into it even if you've never heard of
the channel before
i think you'll want to stick around and
watch this video it's a really
interesting story that highlights a
darker side of entrepreneurship that we
don't often hear about
usually when youtube channels die they
do it slowly
the content gets boring and repetitive
and view numbers start decreasing but
that's not the case for business casual
the last video on the channel got nearly
2 million views
and at 40 minutes long it was clearly a
ton of work to put together
so why would a successful channel like
business casual just throw in the towel
all of a sudden
the answer was not what i was expecting
at all
and contains a really important lesson
for entrepreneurs working on any big
project
not just youtube creators long story
short the folks behind business casual
are suing youtube
which is pretty weird because it seems
like youtube has been quite good to the
channel in general
business casual has nearly a million
subscribers and none of their content
seems to be controversial or demonetized
but if you scroll through the business
casual twitter feed
you will see that whoever is running the
account now is on a crusade against
youtube
in fact the twitter account has posted
basically the same tweet
every day for the last hundred days
straight so i had to figure out what was
driving this
as a little bit of backstory business
casual was started by this guy
jordan kuzminov he lives in bulgaria and
started the channel back in 2016 when he
was studying
business at the rotterdam school of
management i went back through some of
his old reddit posts and he seems like a
really genuine guy
he's just super interested in
entrepreneurial stories the channel grew
significantly over the past few years
and he was even able to bring on a
narrator and animators to help make the
videos
the channel currently has about 80
million views which means that it could
easily have generated a million dollars
in revenue
across youtube ads and sponsorship deals
but looking at jordan's linkedin profile
it seems like he ended his relationship
with the channel in september of 2019
so i started looking into what happened
around that time i'm not a hundred
percent sure
but it looks like he either sold part or
all of the channel
to a guy named alex edson who runs a
company in scottsdale arizona
named ebrands this guy alex has started
a few different businesses
and has been involved with a bunch of
youtube channels over the past few years
and it's alex's name on the youtube
lawsuit that business casual is filing
so it looks like alex is really the one
driving everything now
and constantly posting to twitter
interestingly the business casual
twitter account actually posted the full
243-page lawsuit
so i read through it to get an idea of
what's really going on here basically
the lawsuit comes down to some pretty
standard copyright infringement claims
essentially it looks like another
youtube channel took clips from business
casual videos
and used them in new videos without
permission from the business casual team
for obvious reasons
i'm not going to show any of the
copyrighted footage but if you want to
check it out
i'll link to the clips in the
description below the actual offending
clips are fairly short
one is just seven seconds long and it's
just a slow
zoom on a public domain image it's clear
that the video was stolen
but it's not like they re-uploaded a
whole video or anything like that
youtube actually did take down the
videos that contained the offending
clips
but alex edson doesn't seem to think
that's enough and this is where it gets
really interesting
see the channels that used the
copyrighted footage from business casual
were affiliated with rt which is a
russian state-controlled network
rt used to be called russia today and
has been accused of spreading
disinformation and conspiracy theories
in fact in 2017 rt america was ordered
to register as a foreign agent with the
united states department of justice
so when i first saw the tweets from
business casual in the lawsuit
i thought that maybe this was a personal
vendetta jordan the original creator of
the channel
is from bulgaria after all and
bulgaria's relationship with russia has
been deteriorating over the past decade
i assumed that jordan had taken the
copyright infringement as an opportunity
to punish russia
and maybe he had some personal family
history with russia that motivated him
to stop making new videos
just to focus on this lawsuit but now i
think it's more complicated
jordan isn't listed on any of the
lawsuit filings and it doesn't look like
he's affiliated with the channel in a
meaningful way anymore
alex edson on the other hand is on every
email thread with rt
and youtube representatives and seems to
be the sole driving force behind the
lawsuit so why does this entrepreneur
from arizona want to get russia today
kicked off of youtube so badly
well there are a few factors here first
is the obvious political angle
russia has been a major american rival
for the past hundred years
and tensions between russia and america
were particularly high during the cold
war
more recently russian interference in
the 2016 united states election
became an extremely hot topic donald
trump was a deeply unpopular president
throughout his time in office
and many of his detractors hold russia
accountable for his election more
recently though
the narrative has flipped a bit with
trump kicked off nearly
every social media platform
conservatives have been asking the
question
why is the president of the united
states banned from social media
but russia's state-run accounts aren't
so it's possible that alex edson has a
strong stance here
and wants to get russia kicked off of
youtube for political reasons
but i actually think there's another
layer to this story
i'm not a legal expert but the business
casual lawsuit looks weak to me we're
talking about a few short clips used for
just a few seconds on channels that
publish
literally dozens of videos per day
youtube should definitely take them down
and business casual should receive the
advertising revenue from those videos
since they produced the original content
but it looks like the footage was used
in the context of a much larger video
and the rt channels weren't directly
re-uploading whole videos from business
casual
in order to steal ad revenue if you
consider the actual economic damage done
to the business casual channel here
it looks pretty minimal these clips were
used on arabic channels
and business casual doesn't even post
content in arabic so there isn't really
a good argument that people would watch
the stolen videos
instead of business casual's original
content thus depriving them of views and
ad revenue but i think alex is playing a
bigger economic game with this lawsuit
see youtube and really all the big tech
companies are under immense pressure
right now from the united states
government
as i've mentioned in previous videos
both elizabeth warren on the left
and josh hawley on the right are calling
to break up big tech companies
the last thing youtube needs right now
is a lawsuit gaining steam that makes it
look like they are helping russia spread
disinformation
so this case could easily get settled
out of court
essentially youtube might just pay alex
to go away
that could be a great outcome for him
even though business casual brings in
decent viewer numbers and probably makes
thousands of dollars every month
the content costs a lot to produce and
getting a big payday from youtube
could be significantly more profitable
regardless of what happens with the
lawsuit
it looks like business casual isn't
working on any new content at the moment
so if you're looking to hear interesting
stories about successful companies
you should subscribe to my channel i
just put out a great story about how
discord grew into a multi-billion dollar
company
and next week i'll be releasing the full
story of epic games who created fortnite
in every video i try to not only tell
the story of the company in an engaging
way
but also pull out some key takeaways
that any entrepreneur could apply to
their own business
and there's a big takeaway here about
the business casual story
getting copied happens all the time in
business sometimes it's a direct copy
and you can take legal action but
sometimes it's just a competitive
business and you can't do anything about
it regardless
you can't lose sight of what you're
building the business casual fan base
just wants to watch engaging
documentaries about business
and all this focus on suing youtube
doesn't help them at all when i started
my first company soylant
someone in russia funnily enough
actually put up a copycat website
designed to steal customer credit card
information people thought that they
were buying from us
but they were actually just sending
money directly to these russian hackers
it was annoying but we didn't let it
distract us from our mission of making a
great product if someone copies you
it might be extremely frustrating but
you can't let it consume you
you need to stay focused on your
business there is another option for
business casual though one that would
let them put pressure on russian media
while still making great content they
could start making videos about this
whole story the most successful channels
on youtube
are all personality driven and i know
that i would definitely
watch behind the scenes content of alex
edson's fight against russian media that
would be extremely interesting content
and i think a lot of the business casual
fan base would follow along regardless
of what you think about russia
or where you stand on copyright
infringement i think we can all agree
it's unfortunate when a channel that
produces great content just stops
in the meantime please consider watching
some of the videos on my channel
the youtube algorithm thinks you'll like
this one in particular